horst seehofer lebt ja privat im
ingolstädter stadtteil gerolfing und
genau dort finden auch in diesem jahr
natürlich wieder die gerolfinger
passionsspiele statt wir schalten live
zu monika gruber wie für uns die
generalprobe beobachtet es ist wirklich
er kulturelle höhepunkt des jahres die
gerolfinger passionsspiele erzählen die
unsterbliche geschichte und heiligen
horst es ist alle fünf auf
und das freut der landesführung
auspfiffen
alle fünf jahren sagt er dass er jetzt
doch weitermachen denn sonst machen sie
besser mit der modelleisenbahn spiel
oder dosen ravioli fressen sich mit
seiner frau unterhalten dann doch nicht
gewollt haben ob 40 auf damit barrieren
groß bleibt sonst kann ja keiner
nicht umsonst wurde horst seehofer am
ostermontag bei lebendigem leibe von
papst benedikt heiliggesprochen er war
wunderbar
ich sage wer es schafft gegen jede von
uns eine pkw-maut zu setzen sich nun
reich wird der kann auch wasser in wein
verwandeln
ähnliche bilder und top stimmung
[Musik]
bayerisches brauchtum reißt einfach
jeden mit sie proben sie gerade die
szene wo weder verletzte noch kurz
überlegt hat doch lieber auf die weiber
flehen an nicht wie lange will er
dennoch weiter machen nur so lange bis
ein würdiger thronfolger gefunden ist
also ungefähr maximal 10 20
aber der höhepunkt hierbei den
gerolfinger passionsspiel ist natürlich
das große finale sind in einer vision
der heiland auch monika
[Applaus]